- It's a special tribute to
our men and women in uniform.
Happy Veterans' Day to you
all, here and out there.
(audience cheering)
We all have someone in our families
or close to us who's served.
Do you have someone?
- Yeah, I do.
I've got three sisters,
and two of them married Air Force pilots.
And then I have a nephew
that's an Air Force pilot,
and he's flown dozens of missions overseas
in Iraq, Iran.
And these pilots name their airplanes,
and his plane is named Dr. Phil.
- (laughs) Oh my God!
It's painted on the side of his airplane
and it says "Dr. Phil" there.
I said, "Well, why did
you name it Dr. Phil?"
He said, "Well, I'm delivering the truth."
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] Oh my God, I love
that! His sense of humor.